so the big change in polling in the
Democratic primary during the
Thanksgiving break and really since the
last democratic debate is that Pete
Buddha judge has been rapidly gaining in
the polls while Elizabeth Warren is down
pretty significantly Joe Biden is also
down now before we get into the meat of
this there will be people who say David
Bernie always gets ignored in these
stories I'm not ignoring Bernie Bernie's
up slightly from early October down
slightly from earlier in November not a
huge change in Bernie's polling for the
people who say yang gets ignored I'm not
ignoring him yang is up to three point
three percent but the real big shift is
that Pete Budaj edge mayor of South Bend
Indiana has continued climbing from 4%
in early September to 8% on November
first up to an average of 11% in recent
polls even polling as high as 16 percent
nationally in the last Quinnipiac poll
meanwhile Joe Biden has continued his
decline down to 27% Elizabeth Warren has
also dropped from a campaign high of
nearly 27 in the first week of October
to just under 16 now losing about 11
points nationally this is the lowest
she's been since mid-september so do I
like this no I don't I'm not a Buddha
judge guy III in number one Pete Buddha
judge has parroted this absurd talking
point about Medicare for all calling it
Medicare for all who want it which is a
complete cop-out it's incoherent it's
not really a position and I don't like
it one bit I don't trust it one bit
Buddha judges bizarre reactions when
he's been asked about his struggles with
black Democratic primary voters have
been I mean like I said they've been
bizarre Pete Buddha judges position that
free college isn't good because it leads
to people who earn less subsidizing
people who earn more by paying for their
college through taxes is not a strong
position then more recently Buddha judge
proposed free college for lower and
middle income people so that the kids of
millionaires don't get their tuition
paid and this is an old centrist idea
which I find illogical because the kids
of millionaires are already more likely
to go to college and
they won't even possibly get free State
College makes it easier for them to
argue they shouldn't even be
contributing to anyone going to college
tuition free anyway it's not a good idea
Pete Buddha judge is also way more
religious than I'm interested in having
a president be now I know that we're
supposed to pretend it's fine because
even though he's very religious he's gay
and a Democrat but either he's being
insincere when he talks about his
religiosity or he's just more religious
than appeals to me I would rather have
someone who doesn't make religion such a
central component of their identity as
Pete Buddha judge has Buddha judge has
also signaled automation as being the
primary cause of the loss of
manufacturing jobs in the u.s. that's
pretty my Opik and it ignores much of
the systemic inequality of power in the
economy between workers and companies
which is a huge part of that job loss
now Automation is a concern I'm glad
that he's talking about it because a lot
of elected officials or would-be elected
officials don't but his view seems
either just misguided or ignorant or
insincere and then Buddha judge
participated in meetings months ago with
Democratic Party insiders and big donors
to discuss stopping Bernie at any cost
which is also not good that's like the
worst wing of the Democratic Party so
that's why I'm not a Buddha judge guy
he's doing very well in the polls I
don't know if he has staying power if
he's going to keep growing his support
if you look at early primary States he's
doing very well in Iowa leading he's
leading in New Hampshire but by less
than he's leading in Iowa not doing very
well in Nevada and South Carolina which
are the third and fourth primary states
so my question to you is what do you
believe is behind Buddha judges climb in
the polls is it debate performance is it
that he's being pushed by media or party
elites if you believe that that's what's
going on is it his campaign ads is it
people being disappointed in other
candidates and saying Buddha judge seems
like a reasonable alternative and while
we're at it I'm also curious what you
think is behind Elizabeth Warren's
decline joe biden's I have a sense of
Joe Biden is bad in the debates and the
more he seems to talk the more he seems
to struggle in the polls but Warren
gained four months by getting
opportunities to explain her positions
and ideas and lately she's falling
despite getting lots of talk time at the
latest debate let me know what you
believe is behind Warren's decline and
booted judges climb and then we'll talk
about it more later in the week
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman